Цей будмайданчик розташований за годину їзди
на схід від Берліна.
Ось такий вигляд нині має майбутній газопровід Eugal.
Цими трубами повинен піти газ із Росії -
той, який зараз поки йде через українську газотранспортну систему.
Поки в європейських столицях сперечаються,
чи потрібен "Північний потік-2", тут, неподалік
від кордону з Польщею, повним ходом триває
будівництво суходільного продовження
скандального газогону. І саме ним російський газ
від балтійського узбережжя качатимуть на південь -
до Чехії, а звідти - до одного з найбільших у Європі
газових хабів - "Баумґартен" - в Австрії.
Загалом прокладуть близько 47 тисяч труб,
кожна вагою 15 тонн і 18 метрів завдовжки.
Їх доставляють сюди з Рурської області, зварюють
і закопують уздовж газопроводу OPAL.
Він з'єднує перший "Північний потік" із існуючою
мережею трубопроводів Центральної й Західної Європи.
Загальна довжина ділянки від Балтійського моря
до кордону з Чехією - приблизно 480 кілометрів.
Газопровід у декількох місцях під'єднаний
до існуючої газотранспортної системи Німеччини.
- Eugal - це газогін, що повністю відповідає
приписам ЄС, він інтегрований у німецьку
газотранспортну систему і працює незалежно від джерел.
Це означає, що можна також через інші канали
закачати газ в Eugal і потім
його транспортувати.
Але орієнтована вона, принаймні поки що, повністю
на "Північний потік-2". За проект відповідає
компанія Gascade Gastransport. Це донька
російського "Газпрому" і його німецького партнера -
компанії Wintershall. Основну частину газу планують
прокачувати до кордону з Чехією. Потужності
газопроводу - 51 мільярд кубометрів -
заброньовані до 2037 року.
На будівництві транзитної ділянки від балтійського
узбережжя на півночі ФРН і до кордону з Чехією
на півдні задіяно близько 2000 працівників.
Тему геополітики і глобальних суперечок
навколо "Північного потоку" тут вважають за краще не обговорювати.
- Ми - німецький проект
у німецькій газотранспортній системі,
і всі ці дискусії нас не стосуються.
- Ми в курсі цих суперечок, але наше завдання -
прокладати трубопровід, а політичні рішення
нехай шукають в іншому місці.
Маршрут газопроводу проляже переважно
малонаселеною місцевістю і зачіпає переважно
лише інтереси фермерів. Усім їм запропонували
грошові компенсації.